Amy, you look amazing--
what are you doing?
Weight Watchers,
Jenny Craig?
Yeah, right.
Those take too much
self-control.
Last time I checked,
I wasn't a robot.
Boop-boop-boop,
nope.
How'd you do it?
With Slap Chef.
Slap Chef,
what's that?
It's a new weight-loss
program that takes
decision-making
out of the equation.
How does it work?
( announcer )
First, one of Slap Chef's
world-class chefs
makes you one
of their signature dishes.
Then before you can say
Slap Chef,
they knock it out
of your stupid mouth.
Slap Chef!
What kind of food
do they make?
All kinds.
Sandwiches.
Slap Chef!
Lobster bisque
with crème fraîche.
Slap Chef!
( bleep )
Turkey.
Slap Chef!
Fettucine Alfredo.
But what
if I fight back?
Go for it.
All of the chefs
are trained in the art
of tai chew moi.
I swear to God if you ever
touch me again I'll--
( garbled speaking )
Slap Chef.
What about that
mumbo-jumbo I heard about
Slap Chef being just abject
violence against women?
Hmm?
Slap Chef.